die Fehler macht man jetzt jetzt schon
seit Jahren in der Politiker ist jetzt
nicht das eine was wir jetzt gerade
sehen sondern auch die Jahre vorher
schon wir haben so viel Probleme in
Deutschland über die nicht geredet wird
und die uns immer wieder für die Füße
fallen ja das ist sich nur die Energie
dann ist der Umgang mit Russland da sagt
man hätte man nicht erwarten können also
wer sowas sagt dass man das nicht
erwartet hätte erwarten können was Putin
macht also ich meine die Rede 2002 äh
nehmen wir dann Georgien danach da die
Krim überfallen dann hat er die
Verfassung geändert dass ein
dauerpräsident werden kann wenn man da
als Politiker Politiker nicht merkt was
da vor sich geht frage ich mich was man
überhaupt noch merkt andersrum macht man
denselben Unsinn mit den Chinesen auch
den hofieren wir auch permanent noch was
ist denn wenn der mal sagt so ich
liefere euch nichts mehr wo sind wir
denn dann als Volk die Politiker müssen
langsam anfangen darüber nachzudenken
was denn da überhaupt passiert die
Chinese ist noch viel schlimmer was ist
denn die Konsequenz daraus sie können
doch bei großen Ländern die den
Regierung uns nicht gefallen sagen die
beeindrucken jetzt durch moralische
reden ist nein moralische reden ja wenn
ich mir Europa bin ich mal Europa
vorstelle so wie Europa gedacht war
warum so oft man die ganzen Sachen nach
China aus wir haben genug europäische
Länder naja die die Sachen auch hätten
übernehmen können also ich glaube dass
er weg was die moralischen reden angeht
da kann man in der Tat sagen dass
Deutschland da ganz weit vorne ist keine
früheren französischen Außenminister
vielleicht zusammen da sind wir die
größten wir fahren in der ganzen
Weltraum halten große Reden das fängt ja
schon bei Genscher an im ersten
Golfkrieg Deutschland bezahlt die
Franzosen die Italiener die Engländer
die Amerikaner können kämpfen denken wir
mal an 2011 zurück Fukushima da ist in
Japan ein Unglück geschehen in
Deutschland nicht was hat Merkel gemacht
über Nacht ein paar Tage vor einer
Landtagswahl die gesamte
Energieversorgung politisch auf den Kopf
gestellt diese Entscheidung wurde
getroffen wenn wir heute gucken was die
Leute am meisten stört das ist meine
Prognose ich laufe ja nicht rum und
halte Umfragen aber davon bin ich
überzeugt
die wissen auch dass die Regierung
nichts dafür kann was jetzt in der
Ukraine geschieht natürlich historisch
durch die durch die Kooperation mit
Putin McCain hat mal gesagt ein Mörder
ein Kriegsverbrecher ein Produkt des KGB
da unterschreibe ich jedes Wort und das
hätte man alles besser machen können
aber wie sich das jetzt eskaliert hat im
Februar dafür kann man die Regierung
nicht haftbar machen man muss nur
zweierlei erwarten dass sie das erkennt
und dass sie ganz klare Signale setzt
wir haben die Krise verstanden wir
können für gewisse Dinge nicht aber wir
tun was wir können und Handeln und das
wäre ich sagte schon
Laufzeitverlängerung und nicht nur eine
Rede halten Zeiten Wende die ich gut
fand und wie ein großer Sprung für die
SPD war mit Sicherheit so eine Rede zu
halten das war bemerkenswert von Scholz
aber dann müssen die Panzer auch
geliefert werden denn je mehr Panzer in
der Ukraine sind je mehr man diesen
tapferen Menschen hilft gegen diesen
Kriegsverbrecher die Krieg zu gewinnen
desto schneller sinken auch die
Gaspreise das ist doch ganz einfach
machen
bei vielen auf der Straße das hat der
Buschner gerade auch erinnert ist dass
es zuerst dass das Gefühl viele um die
Menschen dort in der Ukraine geht und
dann erst das Portemonnaie und dann erst
die Gasrechnung das ist wieder klassisch
das hat Italien beantwortet mit einem
Slogan Italy first gibt es eine solche
Tendenz hier in Deutschland ja die gibt
es glaube ich in erster Linie im Osten
Deutschlands aber es gibt ja und sowieso
diesen überbordenden Pazifismus hier wir
halten uns überall raus Waffen schaffen
keine Lösung doch wir sehen in der
Ukraine das Waffen eine Lösung schaffen
nämlich dass ein überfallen ist
gepeinigtes vergewaltigtes Volk sich zur
Wehr setzen kann gegen einen Aggressor
der Zweite Weltkrieg muss ich das
Beispiel bringen das Waffen und Militär
sinnvoll sein können
in dem ersten Teil gesagt haben
deswegen sind doch diejenigen die in
erster Linie mit putinen
zusammengearbeitet
sie widersprechen in fast allem was er
gesagt das ist mit der Atom sogar schon
ziemlich Rot-Grün ausgestiegen aus der
Turm Energie hat Merkel das rückgängig
gemacht hat uns Milliarden gekostet für
die Industrie und das nach Fukushima das
korrigiert worden das hat die Mehrheit
richtig von zweitens wir unterstützen
die Ukraine politisch
ökonomisch humanitär auch militärisch
aber wir wollen den Krieg auch nicht
ausweiten wir wollen keine Alleingänge
machen wir handeln gemeinsam mit den
Amerikanern Franzosen zusammen das
findet die Bevölkerung richtig anders
als sie das hier sagen und zu sagen wir
sollen vorangehen keinen Frieden sagen
sie Waffen schafft den Frieden in der
Ukraine sagt der steingriff Hövel mit
dem Streit machen wir gleich weiter Herr
Bartsch widerspricht auch nach einer
ganz kurzen Pause hier bei Bild die
richtigen Fragen bis gleich
zurück bei Bild die richtigen Fragen in
hochkarätiger Runde heute abend Herr
Bartsch wir haben gerade über die Frage
gestritten schaffen Frieden Waffen wir
schaffen Waffen Frieden so rum in den in
der Ukraine ja oder nein ist es so wie
Frau Wagenknecht sagt dass wir längst
dort Kriegspartei sind ja gut ich meine
der Kanzler spricht vom Wirtschaftskrieg
Robert Habeck spricht von
Wirtschaftskrieg natürlich ohne die
Unterstützung von Deutschland von
anderen Ländern wäre die Ukraine nicht
in dieser Situation das ist ja
unbestritten natürlich sind wir
letztlich Kriegspartei natürlich den
würde ich überhaupt nicht aber da hat
Herr Stegner übrigens sehr recht wir
müssen alles tun und Gott sei Dank sage
ich wird viel getan dass der Krieg sich
nicht ausweitet wenn man so locker mehr
Waffen mehr Waffen erstens entscheidet
das Deutschland nicht das wird immer
noch in Washington entschieden und
solange das da nicht klar ist werden
auch nie schwere Panzer geliefert ganz
klar zweitens die These stimmt nicht
glaub irgendwer dass je mehr Waffen sind
desto erst der Krieg zu Ende glaubt
irgendwer dass man vielleicht in Moskau
auf dem Kreml dann irgendeine Fahne
wehen lässt das ist absurd und es
besteht ein riesen Gefahr ich möchte
nicht dass diese Gefahr befördert wird
ich wünsche mir dass eine
Außenministerin eben wirklich nicht die
oberste Verkäuferin von Waffen ist
sondern alles versucht dass ihr
diplomatisch was hingehen wird immer
gesagt ja putin will ja gar nicht reden
ich kann nur feststellen sowohl beim
Getreideexport als auch beim Gefangenen
Austausch da hat es funktioniert und es
gilt der Spruch von Helmut Schmidt
lieber
100 Stunden verhandeln als eine Minute
schießen
Parteien sehr unterschiedlich bei
bartschalen zu Recht gesagt dass
natürlich eine Koalition aus
Sozialdemokraten grün und Linkspartei
heute ein ganz anderes Deutschland
geschaffen hätten als es mit der
Regierungsparteien der FDP dabei ist um
noch mal die Frage von vorn zu
beantworten
Fenster öffnen natürlich jederzeit doch
die Wahrheit ist putin will nicht
verhandeln also diese Unterstellung der
würde da sitzen und quasi auf dem Anruf
warten ist nicht richtig hat die babac
jetzt so nicht gesagt aber manche sage
ich meine in der in der insbesondere
übrigens spannender Weise in der rechten
Szene behaupten das ja die AFD ist das
muss man in aller Klarheit sagen da
manchmal wirklich ein Stück weit eine
Kolonne des Kremls auch bei den Debatten
im Deutschen Bundestag und ich finde es
fürchterlich denn dort sitzt der aggress
und wir sind in einer Situation in der
sich jeder Frieden wünscht zuallererst
doch die Menschheit teilweise das
allererster würde der jetzt handeln
komme so ich danke sage ist sofort
zuallererst die Menschen in der Ukraine
würden sich den Frieden wünschen und wir
alle doch gemeinsam aber richtig ist
dass diese Koalition auch dort eine
Zeitenwende gemacht hat und
Hans-Dietrich Genscher ich bin davon
überzeugt hätte das gleiche getan
natürlich einen Kanal offen lassen gar
keine Frage aber in einer Situation wo
ein freies Land was ich in Richtung
Europa bewegen wollte aggressiv von
außen angegriffen wird
völkerrechtswidrig dass man da
unterstützt anders als es früher
Regierung getan haben wir liefern jetzt
Waffen in ein kriegs- und Krisengebiet
ist wirklich was anderes und ich bin mir
sicher vor dem Hintergrund der
Aggression aus dem Kreml hätte
Hans-Dietrich Genscher auch so
entschieden ist dieses nämlich total
offen nach Moskau werden sie in einigen
Wochen oder Monaten im Grunde dasselbe
sagen in der SPD wie Frau Wagenknecht
heute nein ich habe überhaupt nichts
gemein mit dem was da formuliert wenn
denn das sind Angriffskrieg und der
Putin diesen kriegsarbeiter und die AFD
ist nicht nur ein Stück weit sondern ist
komplett sozusagen die Stimme der
Autokraten aber ich glaube dass die
Unterstützung die wir der Ukraine geben
so gut sein muss es geht sie muss im
militärischen Teil gemeinsam mit den
Verbindungen gemacht hätten es muss
immer noch darüber geredet werden wie
man am Ende muss eine diplomatische
Lösung ständig und wir müssen auch
vermeiden dass der Krieg Ausfälle sagen
um 20 Menschen auf der Straße die zum
Teil noch so erinnern wie das bei ihren
großen Eltern war im Krieg wir haben die
Angst davor haben deswegen die Frage
übrigens hinter verschlossenen Türen
passiert sowas wenn wenn Scholz mir tut
hätte dafür kritisiert waren ich finde
es gut dass er das tut und natürlich ist
das schwierig dazu am Ende zu einer
Entscheidung aber man muss dahin kommen
ich kann mich gut Hinsehen als wir vor
ein paar Monaten langsam macht das doch
mit den Getreide bekommen nichts das
geht nicht damit die Minen sind im
Schwarzen Meer dann schießen ihre es ist
gegangen außer in der türkische
Präsidentin und nee kein Friedensstifter
ist macht das das wünsche ich mir eher
von anderen ich glaube die Logik immer
mehr Waffen wird am Ende des richten ist
falsch ich tue mich schwer mit dem
Waffen liefern aber ich habe das
mitgetragen das im Bundestag ja auch
beschlossen dass wir die Ukraine
unterstützen müssen wir auch tun aber es
muss genauso Öffnung dafür geben dass es
am Ende gelöst hat denn ich sage Ihnen
auch eins die ganzen Energieprobleme
werden wir nicht lösen und der Krieg
ewig dauern ich habe eine Sorge dass
geschäftlichen Gesellschaften sprechen
mit amerikanischen französischen
Kollegen die sagen auf Dauer Inflation
hoch Energiepreise hoch Flüchtlinge die
Waffenlieferung führen zunächst auf
Dauer ist es sehr schwer sie sehen in
Italien jetzt schon Rechtsregierung in
Schweden leider auch eine wer weiß was
in Amerika passiert das ist ein Problem
und deswegen müssen wir uns auch darum
kümmern dass die diplomatischen Kanäle
wenn ich sie nicht verstanden habe sagen
sie ja mehr Waffen damit wir nicht den
Krieg verlängern sondern verkürzen um
dann ganz schnell den Gaspreis wieder
runterzukriegen aber sicher ich meine
Herr Bart sagte eben wir wollen den
Krieg nicht ausweiten hier tun wir das
marschiert die Ukraine morgen auf Moskau
nein die würden doch nie die ist schon
die Frage ob sie in die Krim gehen
würden oder in die schon 2014 besetzen
Gebiete das ist schon fraglich wenn Sie
das tun wäre das auch alles völlig in
Ordnung ausweiten wird ihn Krieg
jedenfalls nicht die Ukraine und auch
keine der Nationen die die Ukraine
unterstützen ob ich noch nicht zweitens
sie ist es aber dann ist der kriegt
schnell
das nämlich vielleicht weiter den Krieg
aus und dann hätten wir ein und laufen
weg hätte man das mit nach dem
Sudetenland nicht auch anders machen
lösen müssen oder irgendein Senator oder
36 gesagt hat wäre hätte ich bloß mit
Hitler Vergleiche genau das der zweite
Punkt
sie haben gesagt in den USA wird
entschieden welche Waffen wir liefern
die us-botschafterin hat hier im
deutschen Fernsehen gesagt und auch auf
Twitter das muss jedes Land selber
entscheiden
Sie sich nur ganz kurz einmal vor was in
der Ukraine heute los wäre wenn der
Westen keine Waffen geliefert hätte wäre
das ein
vergewaltigungskonzentrationslager mit
Toten und Kriegsverbrechern das Land wer
der wird im Erdboden gleich gemacht das
wäre heute ohne Waffen immer wieder
angesprochen wurde Herr Dörr werden wir
das erleben dass wir in Richtung das war
auch die Kritik als Parteikollegen in
Richtung einer die Industrialisierung in
Deutschland laufen und das immer mehr
Firmen von den USA angezogen werden
immer wieder große deutsche
mittelständische Unternehmen die
reihenweise in die USA fahren
wir ja Dinge in der Politik ich habe es
vorhin angesprochen die Dinge die auch
sogar im Koalitionsvertrag stehen große
Strukturreform in der Energiepolitik
andere Bereiche andere Bereiche kann man
fortsetzen das ist jetzt wie unter einem
brendlass klar dass das jetzt schneller
passieren muss das ist schwer genug
einige Dinge haben wir schon entschieden
Ausbau erneuerbare beispielsweise haben
wir gemeinsam entschieden ich füge hinzu
insbesondere beim Thema offshore bringt
auch mehr Stabilität in den Netze aber
ich sage in dieser Situation auch da
sind wir jetzt unterschiedlicher Meinung
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
für die Übergangszeit so also diese
strukturentscheidung treffen wir und das
Ziel ist natürlich deswegen ist die FDP
in der Bundesregierung dass dieses Land
ein wohlstandsland ist in dem das
soziale aufstiegsversprechen geht
natürlich bleibt selbstverständlich das
muss das Ziel sein aber das erreichen
wir nicht das sage ich ganz offen durch
impacement-politik gegenüber Russland
das ist nicht von ganz schnell Ja oder
Nein schaffen sie das Herr Stegner Herr
Dörr ohne russisches Gas dieses
wohlstandsversprechen ja oder werden wir
schaffen ja natürlich wenn wir das
schaffen nur noch kaum noch den
Prozentanteil den wir hatten wir reden
hier Norwegen wir hätten es eh machen
müssen wir hätten es doch eh machen
unabhängiger ja denn unabhängig von
diesem fürchterlichen Angriffskrieg aus
dem Kreml unabhängig davon war doch klar
dass diese krasse Abhängigkeit von
Russland energiepolitisch falsch war
Wert ist ohnehin diversifizieren müssen
glauben
dass wir das alle miteinander dass wir
das alle in Deutschland schaffen ohne
russisches Gas diesen Wohlstand zu
behalten er wir dürfen ja gar nicht
anders machen alles andere wäre ja so
kontraproduktiv es wird jetzt vorerst
keinen Frieden geben ja ich habe
entstehen oder auch schon gehört bei
Markus Lanzen auch die Frau Wagenknecht
ja wir müssen die die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen so viel wie wir irgendwie
nur können aus dem ganz einfach und es
gibt ein paar Möglichkeiten wieder zu
Gesprächen zu kommen das eine ist die
Bevölkerung in Russland gewährt
irgendwann auch mal auf und sagt so pass
auf jetzt ist aber langsam gut wir haben
jetzt 300.000 Soldaten die er da geholt
hat das sind alles junge Leute ja
die haben Eltern ja und ob die das so
lustig finden wenn ihre Kinder nicht
mehr nach Hause kommen glaube ich auch
nicht und ich glaube auch dann fällt
diese russische Propaganda mal das ist
so eine der Möglichkeiten die man ja im
Auge behalten muss was den Krieg beenden
kann beziehungsweise die
Gesprächsbereitschaft von einem Putin
und von deiner Frau vielleicht ein wenig
passiert weil wenn man das sieht wir
haben Frau Frau bärbock gehabt er Labor
kommt rein hält seine Rede dreht Strom
geht wieder ja das ist eine Art und
Weise diplomatisch gesehen
also unmöglich wäre da noch wer da noch
gestrahlt oder geprahlt das letzte das
geht überhaupt gar nicht ja die sind
nicht gesprächsbereit also wie schaffe
ich das Gespräch
erreicht jetzt kommt noch schwedene
Fingern die NATO auch schlecht für
Russland gut für unsere baltischen
Freunde okay jetzt ist eben nicht und er
hat keinen seiner Christina erreicht
trotzdem darf man nicht vergessen
Russland ist die zweitgrößerto Macht der
Welt dem Putin sein Soldaten leider
schnurz die Opposition ist mutig aber
die meisten sind knasten werden
unterdrückt und ob die Diktatur so
schnell fällt das weiß ich nicht ich
hoffe Sie haben Recht
ich habe die Angst nicht dass der
putinator sage ich Ihnen ganz ehrlich
ich glaube damit arbeitet er jetzt schon
seit Jahren ich kann ich will auch gar
nicht sprechen
davon ab bei unserem Wohlstand bei ihrem
wohlstandsversprechen gewesen und ich
will ein Brot auf diesen Tisch legt weiß
jemand in diesen Tagen was Brot kostet
der Bartsch Leib Brot was zahlen sie im
Moment dafür was dieses Brot können zum
Beispiel diese da das wird irgendwie so
bei 3,60 € Kosten
4,60 € oder 3,60 € Ende 3 Euro im Moment
bei diesem kleinen Leib
rot.minister aus Nordrhein-Westfalen hat
gesagt wir werden dann kurz über 8 €
liegen wird es ein Luxusgut er ist dafür
kein Luxusgut werden schauen Sie Herr
Laumann und ich wir können uns das Logo
ja deswegen muss man dort etwas tun
deswegen sage ich bei diesem zum
Beispiel ist hier das Thema bei
Grundnahrungsmittel ob man die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Null nimmt es muss
gehandelt werden dass der Punkt oder
gibt es mehrere Stränge es ist doch
nicht so niemand in der Politik hat
jetzt den Knopf und sagt das machen wir
das alles gut das wird ein Prozess sein
und da sind Fehler in der Vergangenheit
gemacht worden aber jetzt werden aktuell
in der Gegenwart zu viel Fehler gemacht
denn wenn wir so weiter tun und das
machen wir aktuell wird die Inflation
bald bei 10% sein und der Leib rot wird
noch teurer werden so und das können
sich wir hier alle Leisten aber es gibt
jetzt doch schon die Eltern die sagen
ich kann meinem Kind kein Eis kaufen da
haben wir noch ein Problem und deswegen
sage ich das auf der anderen Seite die
gibt die milliardenschiffe in dieser
Zeit und im übrigen verdienen sogar
Menschen auch an den Waffen die wir
liefern da finde ich muss man einen Teil
abholen das ist dringend notwendig dann
kriegen wir auch sozialen Ausgleich hin
ansonsten kann es so sein dass genau der
sehr gefährdet ist der soziale
Zusammenarbeit das will hier vermutlich
niemand also ihr auch auch Herr dürrw
will nicht den sozial Reichensteuer oben
drauf und so weiter um es denen die
Arbeiten gehen und es nicht ganz so
dicke haben den Alltag überhaupt
bezahlbares um den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland zu ruinieren das sind ja
mittelständische Unternehmer von dem wir
reden Arbeitsplätze geschaffen haben all
das sind substanzsteuern also mit
anderen Worten da werden werkzeilen
besteuert in dem Menschen arbeiten aber
ökonomischer Quatsch aber was man
natürlich machen muss ist die Preise
Unterbringen der Grund warum Christian
nittner am Wochenende von der
gaspreisbremse gesprochen hat ist doch
genau der dass das mit den 8 Euro nicht
passiert
insofern ist das der Grund warum
unfassbar teuer ist und das wollen wir
runterbringen und auf der anderen Seite
die Kapazitäten ausweiten wir haben das
jetzt alles diskutiert das Ziel muss
sein das Wurzel bei der Übel bei dass
das Übel bei der Wurzel zu packen nicht
im Nachhinein den Schaden entstehen zu
lassen Dietmar Bartsch wäre
wahrscheinlich da der vorschlagen und
dann über sozialen Ausgleich sondern von
Anfang an das Problem minimieren
gehen in diesen Herbst und Winter und
bauen
wärmehallen wo sich die Menschen mit
Decken wärmen können in diesem Winter
das ist im Moment unser kleiner
ganz ehrlich sagen wenn Land wie
Deutschland das nicht kann wir haben das
bei Corona gezeigt mit dem
Kurzarbeitergeld zum Beispiel wo wir
eine Menge für Geld ausgegeben haben
wenn dann wie Deutschland wer soll das
denn eigentlich hinbekommen wir werden
das schaffen wir werden das schaffen und
müssen das auch hinkriegen und ich bin
sicher wir werden das auch zusammen
hinkriegen da wird sich jeder
kompromissmäßig bewegen müssen so ist
das aber am Ende wird es Vorschläge
geben das darf nicht 8 Euro kosten das
können die Leute sich nämlich nicht mehr
leisten und das kann nicht das Ergebnis
sein denn sonst holen sie nämlich die
Rechtsradikalen Abschlussfrage ja oder
nein Herr Schäfer sie sind vom Fach
werden wir in diesem Herbst Winter ein
Blackout erleben in Deutschland aus weil
es ist halt sehr viel passiert im
Bereich der Heizung weil die Heizungen
halt eben jetzt alle umgerüstet werden
auf Wärmepumpen energiefachberater und
angemacht werden wird spannend werden
wir ein schleckerhaut Erleben sagt er
[Musik]